foreign
[Music]
the benefit that Khan Academy brings to
our school district is being able to
provide a platform that provides
individualized practice study skill the
ability for students to increase their
knowledge proficiency the support that
Khan Academy provides us is one-on-one
and tailored to our district they are
extremely understanding of our scenario
and what we are looking to gain from the
platform with the Khan Academy District
partnership we take our highly
efficacious and trusted content the
content in Khan Academy lines up so well
with our course curriculum when we dig
for specific subjects get something that
is wanted that a lot of teachers already
believe in we've seen the data we've
seen that it works with our students our
growth in our SAT has been proven and we
supercharge your classroom with student
two admin level reporting to give you
data-driven insight into the needs of
your students I really do like how the
data was very easy the reports are very
easy and it was easy for our teachers to
be able to read those and to be able to
guide their lessons as well everything's
a One-Stop shop so that helps a lot to
speed up the process and get them on the
platform which is more we want them to
be for the learning to take place
whether your district is large or small
our expert team of educators are here to
support your entire District you'll get
a support team committed to empowering
District leaders site leaders coaches
and teachers so each student can Master
grade level skills and address their
unique learning gaps Khan Academy really
listens to you to find out what are your
professional development needs and how
can we best tailor our professional
developments the needs of your District
guidance along the way we never felt
that we were in this process alone it
takes a lot off of me and now we can go
in start the lessons the teachers can go
in and start looking at those skills
that they need to prepare their lessons
for through Khan Academy and then we're
using it as part of our intervention if
you use Khan Academy you will see
success
and that is not an anomaly for us we saw
it time and time again I'm Sal Khan and
I founded Khan Academy many years ago as
a not-for-profit organization because I
always wanted to ensure that we put
impact for your learners above any
notion of profit Khan Academy is the
most used platform in the country and
actually the world to address unfinished
learning we're going to work with you to
accelerate your learners at grade level
and give you and your teachers the data
that they need to support that learning
to learn more about how a Khan Academy
districts partnership can provide your
district with the personalized support
you need connect with our District's
team today